[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome mr.
Jorge Jiao president of Honor
[Music]
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
welcome to join honor 20 serious long to
event welcome to London as that's what
India's that's what I'm I'm really happy
to see so many friends and London these
tides ebb goose and sign and that's
better and also here we want to talk to
you using our product our Interbrand
five and a half years and we design our
product for young people and in the past
years we grow together with young we
encourage the young people for train no
matter what happened no matter what kind
of challenge they become it just smell
and overcome them
so today I know globally in my hometown
China millions of people are watching
today's the launch event so for honor we
won't be the benchmark for young people
how to overcome the difficulties and how
to do yourself and how to face a
challenge and we will talk and
communicate with the world using our
products technology and innovation in
the past years this day and euro
together with global young people we
deeply involved in young people terror
activity extreme spot aspirin
the gameplay we also invite global young
fans to join the honor family joined
honor team to become honoured chief
experience officer to turn on a product
- looking for the defense in the give us
about the future requirement shall
really I want to use this opportunity to
appreciate an honor customer and on
offense you are the engine and the power
to ship hot on a girl sent your nuts and
today in this special time I'm really
happy to introduce some new member of
our family that Eddie very famous
professional the football player in your
kind it's the honor the brand ambassador
and then re also the game player he's a
very capable father
this mobile smartphone the gameplay and
also he sell a lot in his social network
and we also have lobbying insolent very
famous singer
you are in Czech Republic it is no board
the unpure champion and mira in the face
in the diner welcome to join the honor
family and they also want to say hello
to everybody
show the video if you take a look
[Music]
under my determination
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whoo [ __ ]
okay welcome them again okay
Auto Club is unlined
platform and the community for the honor
fence joined together so already the big
family every trader that fans join the
and sarolea culture and make friends
complicated about a technology the
gameplay and so on so they are like you
know the brother and sisters and we also
today we moved its online community to
offline we build up honor life this is
the own life in community build our city
in China and you can see that the
fantastic a building like pyramid in
fact the local people also caught us on
her period
now other life including the honor cafe
and that gives all yard
they also join together to eat clearance
and let his product and technology this
is a home for honor fans join together
and we will bring on her life to
different cities in the filter next
month's your lungs on her life in
Chengdu and then in the future in Madrid
Moscow Milan and Paris and so on so
we'll provide a different life I mean
the orders their life to young people
and we also that put the best design in
our product in the past honor cooperate
with Makino EEP and the fashion designer
the very intent for smartphone and
wealthy time so you can see that today
honor the design philosophy is we
combine innovation technology rates
status and faster so we call this the
tactic this honored the product design
philosophy and you can see that in the
past three years we launched on 8:00 on
a night and the order came to show this
design chant maybe you still remember
for the owner eight staffer blue in
smartphone industry if the first time we
bring the so brilliant cutter into the
idiots in design in glass your green for
on a nine and offend him blue and
defendant green for honor King the
Phantom carriage is eras hinging sure
daddy make smartphone design now so
boring and today I'm really proud in
this dies honor belongs on Attorney
series capture weather
so today I will gather you entered world
of venery let's stop talk on earth
unnecessary design I'll radio you
getting into the water
manner period take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it makes you feel
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone this is outstanding
honorton ePro okay
thank you I can guarantee that today
you'll see the design if first time
healthy in the smartphone okay thank you
Matt thank you so you can see will you
look at aren't any pro moralize you'll
see enough spice behind the other
control and how we make this happen and
tell you in the first time that we used
the dynamic holographic design so this
the first time we used in the smartphone
industry the back cover includes three
layers
glass layer Kara later in the Darth
Vader and the medical things that happen
between these three layers will light
shooting on the are not any problem the
back Horus you can see the reflexive the
dabs layer to reflect light give you the
feeling the light entered miss furious
spice so it's making a really amazing
effect we call this sweetie the triple
the mass process and technology and you
can look at again and like not to now
show in the cour in the surface the cour
moralized enter the world of venner in
other handy for all we adopt the false
idea of the design so can perfectly mass
your hand held you know the field we are
comfortable also to support one hand
operation unattended forever the
configure 6.8 26 ins the punch hole that
is flight and today in this industry the
only way we honor and the sub song has
disappeared hold a solution in today i'm
really proud for the pentacle sites the
are 20 proud and honored 20 how the
smallest design and even smaller then
galaxy' has 10 and we can make this i
mean the extreme design using our
technology in the almost in vietnam when
you play the games and you do not impact
your operation and for this 6.0 26 inch
display today it's missing okay the
display become bigger and bigger I want
to wear an operation honored to deploy
20 series the size just like a
traditional there are five points
trillions so for you wear an operation
it's no pressure and also that we stop
we support set among its fingerprint
sensor so when you put cup
pick out the honorton a cirrus you're
ready unlock that this flight we are
very convenient
everybody knows today the physical the
fingerprint sensor the unlocks
sensitivities better than the in screen
display we enjoyed this benefit at same
time we have specially designed for the
surfing or freight they said we
integrated the fingerprint sensor with
the power button so when you push one
second
there's fingerprint button you can
activate the white car the voice
assistant then you if you call somebody
use acid how the owner turned in service
they can easier it of any of the organs
in a very simple today we bring two
colors for honor to the pro this is a
phantom blue already amazing right it's
a combination blue and green so that in
the different light for example in
insights where you see there aren't any
problem it's a little blue colors but in
outside if in the sunshine you can see
the moral I like green
see another very special design we call
this phantom car you cannot cut is just
the pure blue and green second one
phantom black
amazing right this is I mean the
Terminator of like and the purple so
it's very difficult for us to define
it's like or purple something else so
family regard it's a phantom black the
very special design
now we Gary we entered the world of
winner for the owner 20 we bring the
three colors suffer blue the like the
deep awesome and very classic mean that
like the third one
Gandhi you your neck it during the
summertime Atlantic white yeah it to
look so cruel during the summertime yeah
okay and we also cooperate with Moschino
to bring honor
what's Kinoko designer honor today so
this is a really the math keynote us
down this is not a mosquito phone and
for more people decide it's and not
mosquito wallpaper
okay we're status design sense our
mosquito colleague thank you
and also that the Moschino team designed
very beautiful case the carrots were
beautiful and then we show you that
honorton a serious klaxon and I can
guarantee that its model they it's a
fabulous amazing that bring you enter
the world of manner the cap to the
vendor and you need the entered of water
vendor and then the reuse introduce the
pro grade the camera solution for honor
Taniya saris and today we will need
travel in for every day we won't have
the beautiful photos there on a social
network it's crime Facebook and we study
thousand millions of the photos and we
understand rather vast the camera this
should feed for the different scenario
so the interchangeable ins if necessary
so when we use that single as a camera
reflection camera we know that we change
the lens and this make us a mean Kanda
you see in the different scenario far or
close but for the DSLR the camera the
hell also advantage and the disadvantage
they are too heavy it not convenient to
carry and then of course it's too costly
and today's our solution can solve all
these issues give you all the benefits
that's it our pro great car camera
solution
you can see the are for dishonored and
pro we configure them one for eight
megapixels the main camera with F 1.4
after sights this world the biggest
after site support the OAS system once
you provide an angle camera in the one
telephoto camera with the OS system and
one the Microsoft camera so the one
camera we have we call this the pro
great called camera system and with
honor 20 from the standards the photos
with the main camera you can have this
photo and then supervisor angle and then
with the californica Murrah and the
Microsoft you can have front and close
so the one honor
Tony Pro can give you the fall different
experience standards telephoto and the
supervisor angle and the mark result for
honor 20 series posts for the honor 10
April and honor 20 is support called
camera solution and for honor Hindi we
also configured for 8 megapixels main
camera and the 16 the megapixels the
super wide angle camera when that's
camera 1 Microsoft camera with the
honorton the problem we can guarantee
you're starting serious for both night
and day and these photos taking in thing
about in same place same purchasing and
the different time so you can see the
speed
there two photos perfect a massive heart
and you can see that even for native you
shot you can see the more details now
very beautiful an orator need serious
support by our to claret him out but if
the AI clarity mode you can zoom to see
them more clouds things and drew McGill
so even for you can see the details of
the grass and plant let's enjoy this and
in the build for the next shot so
everybody want to have these kind of
photos when you travel to some beautiful
place and how to make this happen easily
we know that the upper side sensor sites
and also the image stabilization is the
key therefore this natural shot in the
honor turned in series reconfigured one
secondly ins the sensor size the
compared with iPhone hands max and
Galax Garrick system plus the 25% ladder
for the sensor size in the our antenna
Pro have the world the biggest of 1.4
after size you can compare with others
in the F 1.4 after side in first Lt in
the smartphone thank you much
and this I mean of1 point for the other
sides that can support 60% more light
intake compared with the iPhone 10
smacks 50% more and we configured do for
axis the OS system for main camera and
telephoto camera we have very good and
strong the hardware of course the
software and the emails processing the
algorithm is very important on antenna
serious support yes a super night mode
so one photos combine the 16x powder we
use the a either processing ability to
combine them together have this
beautiful phone a beautiful photos and
then I disclose this photo is sought by
the honor to any pro in potagooo in fact
for everybody it's an honor to the
problem this Jang the photo performance
you can with handheld no neither trap
hot you can show this cannot photo by
ourselves so our strategies to make our
body can solve the professional photo by
yourself in the because so some
comparison aren't any progress the
iPhone has max for this net shot you can
see this big difference and you can see
that you will honor 10 Pro you can see
more details
especially on Orton April's support
extremely high the [ __ ] up to 200
4,800 it is son [ __ ] even hiding the
professional stingless a reflection
camera now you can compare the with
galaxies 10 class and the iPhone has max
as a mass mass higher this extremely
high de [ __ ]
the helped a lot in the super low
lighting environment I can show you
these photos you can easily identify the
big difference the photos already tell
the story the waves aren't any problem
you can see that the flower and the
plant in the photo I found here's Max
and galaxies 10 class yes sir I'm in the
dark night and today I'm really happy
that my colleague in this launch day
also demonstrate this the camry SE and
also the honor 20 proud that strong the
capability for low light environments
now I will transfer to my colleagues hi
George
hi thank you very much for joining us
everyone good afternoon so we're going
to be trying a low-light camera
comparison test between the all new
honor 20 Pro the Samsung Galaxy S 10
plus and finally the iPhone 10s max now
before we actually get started with the
test we just quickly dim the lights
please